et
si nos élites politico médiatiques aux
financières étaient en réalité des
hommes lézards qui se nourrissent de nos
peurs et nous contrôler par télépathie
pour gouverner le monde à notre insu
complot
[Musique]
reptiles humanoïdes reptilien recto id
dinosauroïde hommes les arceaux rial
draconien dragons ils ont plein de noms
différents et encore je vous ai pas
parlé dépend où les à l'idée les
sardines mais ils se sont pourtant une
seule et même espèce une espèce super
intelligent qui veut dominer le monde
dans l'ombre selon cette célèbre théorie
du complot les reptiliens ont donc
infiltrer les plus hautes sphères du
pouvoir de la finance et les médias
barack obama un reptile emmanuel macron
délire katy perry ans qui viennent ed
sheeran en un an pas touche est chaud
quant à leur origine il ya plusieurs
versions comme toujours peut-être qu'il
s'agirait d'hybride entre des humains et
des reptiles qui remonte aux
civilisation mésopotamienne plusieurs
milliers d'années avant jésus-christ
comme quoi la zoophilie ça date pas
d'hier peut-être aussi que les hommes et
les femmes les arts serait des lointains
descendants des dinosaures peut-être
encore que les reptiliens viendrait de
l'espace et plus précisément de l'étoile
alpha draconis dans la constellation du
dragon c'est trop beau pour être un
hasard à ce sujet là en 1967 un officier
de police américain sous hypnose s'est
souvenu avoir été enlevé dans une
soucoupe volante par des extraterrestres
qui avait une légère apparence de
reptiles et qui possédait un insigne en
forme de serpent et les sur le torse un
témoignage imparable non quand beaucoup
pensent que c'est un canular à abbas ont
alors en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que ces redoutables les arts se terrait
dans un réseau de galeries souterraines
à l'intérieur de notre planète mais
attention ces reptiles là ne sont pas
coachées par un rat en peignoir et ne se
repose pas de pizza mais bel et bien du
main et en particulier de l'énergie
négative engendrée par la peur et la
haine qu'on ressent bien notre cerveau
reptilien bien sûr du coup la france est
probablement un buffet à volonté pour
les hommes lézards
et oui donc ces créatures diaboliques
nous manipulerait par télépathie pour
faire ressortir ce qu'il ya de pire en
nous la peur l'agression le conflit la
culpabilité le manque de compassion et
l'intolérance pour ensuite mieux se
nourrir de nos énergies négatives mais
là vous allez me dire si un machin comme
ça essayer de passer inaperçu dans une
foule d'humains ça se faire un peu non
alors oui oui mais non parce que
figurez-vous que les quotidiens ont un
super pouvoir celui de prendre une forme
humanoïde à quelques détails près c'est
d'ailleurs à ça qu'on les démasque quand
je dis on sait les experts d'internet
parmi ces détails figurent l'ossature du
crâne la dimension des oreilles la
langue et surtout la forme des pupilles
si ses pupilles sont soit grosse soit
verticale paf reptilien voilà évidemment
ce genre d' analyse ne se fait pas en
direct dans la vraie vie pour ce faire
on s'appuie sur des vidéos de discours
politique par exemple mais alors pas
n'importe quelle vidéo non plus faut
qu'elle soit bien bien compressé en gros
plus la qualité des gueules mieux c'est
comme ça on peut exploiter le phénomène
de glitch des petits soucis de
compression qui vont déformer l'image
déplacer quelques pixels à droite à
gauche et comme ça on peut y voir des
signes de l'existence des reptiliens bon
je crois que vous voyez où je veux en
venir à ce jour on n'a aucune preuve de
l'existence des reptiles cette théorie
du complot était popularisé au 20e
siècle par un auteur complotistes
britannique david haye qui a une
biographie extraordinaire c'est un
ancien journaliste sportif à la bbc est
élu vert vert la couleur des reptiliens
qui à cause d'une maladie est tombé dans
les médecines alternatives les
philosophies newedge les chakras à la
réincarnation la médiumnité et autres
joyeusetés ça je sens que je vais encore
me faire plein d'amis en commentaire
tout commence quand il va consulter une
médium guérisseuse dans l'espoir de
soulager son arthrite une inflammation
des articulations la voyante lui dit que
socrate le philosophe antique est avec
eux dans la pièce pour la faire courte
elle lui dit que david icke serait un
envoyé pour guérir la terre choisi par
son courage qu'il écrirait plein de
bouquins et que des fois il y aurait des
tremblements de terre à des endroits bon
après il ya plein de péripéties 1 il
entre en transe dans un cimetière
péruvien il ya aussi des histoires avec
des ovni en tout cas ils profitent de
toutes ces expériences pour écrire plein
de livres la médium l'avait prédit il
raconte qu'il est guidé par tout un tas
de gens notamment un chinois du nom de
huang lee mais aussi merlin l'enchanteur
joseph le père de jésus christophe
colomb et même les philosophes francis
et roger becker sans fait du nombre il a
même eu un avis sur la crise du coc vite
19 comme tout le monde en pis pour lui a
été causé par la salle g il a tellement
propager de fake news que youtube
twitter et facebook ont supprimé ses
comptes je vous avais dit qu'il était
haut en couleurs à quand le documentaire
biographique bref encore une fois désolé
de vous décevoir mais a priori les
reptiliens n'existe pas pas en vrai en
tout cas parce que l'on trouve un paquet
dans les mythologies et dans la science
fiction ça oui mais comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est pas de la science
réalité en fait voilà j'ai perdu plein
de honor j'ai perdu ce land
[Musique]